♪ (SOMBER PIANO MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
SPEAKER: DOS is a monolithic
and ruthless group
masquerading as a group
designed to liberate women.
SPEAKER 2: I was just thinking,
like, where are we?
How did we get here?
SPEAKER 3:
This has to be stopped.
SPEAKER 4: So I heard Keith
hasn't been seen for weeks.
I'm pretty sure
he's on the run.
NEWS ANCHOR: Keith Raniere
is charged with sex trafficking,
racketeering,
sexual exploitation of children.
KEITH RANIERE: By being able
to do the most distasteful
of activities,
you're going to be
the agent of change.
Imagine you spent 22 years
trying to build something,
but everybody thinks
it's the devil's work.
SPEAKER 5: People didn't stay
because they were coerced.
They stayed in it
because they really thought
they were making society
and the world better.
That's just next level.
His intent was never about doing
anything good for any woman.
SPEAKER 6:
Keith is very dear to me,
and I know he's innocent.
RANIERE: You know the best way
to train a con artist?
Let the games
that they play work.